hello everyone and welcome to an
incredible game from round nine of this
year's feed Grand Swiss it is Vincent
kimer versus nikal sarin and uh both of
them are having a great tournament but
not the absolute best tournament as the
point of this tournament is to win one
of the two spots in the next fed
candidates tournament and Vincent comes
from a tough loss to yip Peno in the
last round and this game is well a weird
to say the least it's similar to what
we've seen in the Jeffrey Shan game uh
but it's not like
there was a completely new game and then
we go into blunder territory here the
completely new game happens on move 14
and the blunder happens on move 18 but
without analyzing the game very deeply
we will we would have missed the blunder
and we would think it's just a casual
blunder but it's actually a very deep
blunder so that being said let's check
it out um on to on top boards the leader
Fabiano corana was fighting bdan Daniel
Dak their game ended in a draw and the
other pair that was also leading the
tournament VI gu
was playing against Andrea seeno their
game also ended in a draw so let's check
out what happened here Vincent with the
white pieces opens with Pawn to D4 we
have Pawn to D5 Knight F3 Knight to F6
and now Pawn to C4 offering to go uh
into the the the famous Gambit territory
and D captures on C4 we have the Queen's
Gambit accepted on the board E3 we have
Pawn to E6 and now Bishop captures on C4
we have Pawn to C5 uh and castles and
now we have Pawn to A6 now this is a
pretty standard position and it's the
the main line of the Queen's Gambit
accepted where white has some very nice
choices like d captures and C5 this is
White's Top Choice then A4 White's
second Top Choice then Bishop to B3 the
third choice Queen to E2 the fourth
choice and so on and so on uh Vincent
however plays White's 12th Choice uh
currently in the database and that is
Rook to E1 it's a very very rare move
and it has been played a couple of times
nuro salimova played it against anamu
chuk she was able to win this game for
example guesh played it against tunan he
lost that game and also there are some
draws for example alira played it
against mvl gishu played it against
Nakamura also resulting in a draw so
okay Rook to E1 what do you play Knight
to C6 putting pressure on White Center
uh Knight to C3 and now Pawn to B5 so
fairly standard Queen's Gambit moves
attacking the bishop Bishop to D3 and
now
Bishop to B7 but as the Knight is
already developed on C6 you can now go
for this A4 breakthrough as the bishop
is for the moment not controlling the E4
square and that is exactly what Vincent
does Pawn to A4 B4 and now Knight to E4
we have Knight to A5 putting pressure on
the Knight here and Knight captures an
F6 so basically everything the same like
in the game gkes versus leavon Aran that
we mentioned only in that game G
captures on F6 was played um
where where Aran defeated Gish but here
we have a queen captures on F6 uh Pawn
to E4 and now Pawn to H6 and there is
one more game in the database where D5
was played immediately Maxim mlov played
it against Alexander ranov last year in
the Russian Championship uh and that
game ended in a draw but here we have
Bishop to D2 by Vincent and it is now as
of move 14 that we have a completely new
game so uh of course now if black at
some point captures on D4 you will have
uh you will have weakened the B4 pawn
and that's exactly what happen C
captures on D4 and now Pawn to E5 you
cannot recapture the queen is defending
the pawn so E5 and Niall says all right
I will just go back with the queen and
defend my Pawn from d8 Vincent says all
right you are up a pawn for the moment
but your king is still in the center of
the board uh Rook to C1 and the bishop
to E7 now getting ready to Castle and
Vincent launches Pawn to H4 now saying
that he has a very uh nice attacking
formation and that Nial should be very
careful if he decides to actually Castle
King side for example if castles King
side Vincent could go for something like
Bishop to B1 then he could put the queen
on C2 threatens sub checkmating ideas
and it's not very easy for black to play
this for example you cannot capture on
H4 as the B4 Pawn has been weakened so
it's hanging and although although it
can be played you can play something
like D3 the game continues you allow
white to go for a rook lift with Rook E3
maybe then the Knight can move maybe you
can shift The Rook into the attack so
this would be a very very aggressive
game but instead after H4 Niel goes
Queen to B6 first adds another Defender
to the B4 Pawn uh and now Vincent plays
uh Bishop to F4 now if Bishop to B1 the
queen can even come to D3 which is much
better than C2 on C2 the queen can be
contested for example with Rook to C8 uh
and here uh it's an incredibly uh
poisonous territory uh there there's
only one good move that you can play to
give you an example if you Castle now if
you Castle now Bishop to B1 just wins
the game on the spot that's how good
this position is for white to give an
example let's say you play Pawn to H5
because you know that white will simply
play Queen D3 threaten Checkmate you
will play G6 and now you might think
okay it's perfectly fine no it's not
Knight to G5 and this is a a fairly
famous standard attacking formation for
white in in similar setups where you are
threatening all sorts of nasty ideas
like Knight captures and F7 then Queen
captures and G6 uh but to give you an
example if black plays the move as there
really aren't any useful moves just G4
also wins the game if you capture then
H5 is coming this is how you break
through if you don't capture then G
captures sorry then G captures on H5 and
this is how you break through and white
always wins this so the only way to
actually play this after Bishop to F4 uh
and um it's really important uh to show
you why I'm not going to tell you how
how to play against this I'm first going
to show you what was played Bishop to D5
was played and now now Vincent uh is
completely winning here but you have to
figure out how feel free to pause the
video and try to find the winning idea
here while I give you a couple of
seconds so uh for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on
spotting Knight captures on D4 and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show that's exactly what Vincent played
but now I will just show you why Rook 8
to d8 was better first it it's almost
like Niall overlooked this move he
played the exact same line that has to
be played only he should have started
with Rook eight to d8 point is that if
you first play Rook a to d8 and now
white play something let's say Pawn to
H5 as you really want to play this move
uh and now Bishop to D5 the move that
Niel played now Knight captures on D4 is
not nearly as potent because here you
can play Bishop to C5 and after Bishop
to E3 let's say captures captures uh
Queen captures on D4 now B Bishop to B5
check does not win the black queen
because you can play Bishop to C6 and
now you don't care because uh the the
black queen is also defended by The Rook
on d8 so that's why Rook eight to d8 is
such a potent move and here you'd have
nothing better than to trade captures
captures you're going to capture here
with check King E7 and okay the game
continues nothing spectacular but in the
game after Bishop to D5 uh now Knight
captures on D4 is actually well just
very very strong and while you could
continue playing this without capturing
the Knight it's very hard to actually
find a useful move uh whatever you play
you play something like H5 you want to
prepare G6 then comes Bishop D E3 and
Vincent will always have this Advantage
U uh of of uh sort of Nik just
blundering the D4 Pawn so it's something
that we always mention that a grandmas
will never never do they will never
admit a mistake so here it would seem
Nial commits to his mistake and he plays
Queen captures on D4 and he will get
quite a lot of counterplay for his
sacrificed Queen uh however Bishop to B5
with check okay he he does it win the
queen a captures on B5 Queen captures
and now B captures on A4 and now look at
this if A3 is played you have the bishop
here you have the Rook on the a file
preparing uh to push the pawn if uh
black is allowed to do this then Vincent
could be in a lot of trouble so here
there is only one way to actually force
a win here which I'm sure some of you
saw even in the previous pause the video
moment but just in case some of you
haven't feel free to pause the video
again and try to find this continuation
of this variation while I give you a
couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on
continuing this brilliancy and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is Rook to C7 that's the only move
that stops paon A3 and you're probably
wondering how does this stop pon A3 well
if Pawn to A3 Rook captures on E7 that's
how you stop it and if King captures now
Queen captures on B4 comes with check
and once the king moves you can give a
check or you don't have to and then you
capture on A3 and you eliminate um any
in all counterplay black might have had
for that sacrificed Queen however after
Rook to C7 Bishop to d8 was played
attacking The Rook but now just Rook to
A7 and once this Rook gets traded off
you will not have the the much needed
support to advance that past a pawn down
the board or soon to be past a pawn you
still have to move the king or Castle
the king and bring the other Rook into
the game but that's that's just a lot of
moves Rook captures on A7 Queen captures
and now castles A3 you you you have
nothing to support the pawn with so you
have to bring the Rook into the game but
now Bishop to D2 and now uh well pawns
will start falling Knight to C6 was
played attacking the queen but now the
A4 Pawn Falls Bishop to E7 defending on
B4 Now Pawn to H5 we have Rook to d8 uh
and now Rook to C1 just putting pressure
on that Knight here so you still cannot
capture it because the bishop on D2
would still be hanging so Queen to A6 we
have Pawn to B3 now the pawn is nicely
defended but just Queen to B6 and he was
in this position un move 30 that nikin
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here uh for those of you
who like it when I finish the games how
the game might continue is well you have
to create some sort of a an advant that
will enable you to win now you uh
definitely will be threatening Rook
captures here and then Queen captures on
d8 as you will remove the defender of
The Rook so let's say Rook to D7 is
played now you will move the bishop
again now your threatening Rook captures
here to just pick up two pieces for the
rook and once the Knight moves now you
play Bishop to E3 uh and now you are
well basically you want to get your rook
and queen to the back rank but the
Knight is preventing you from doing that
the Knight is guarding the C8 Square so
you might play Bishop to C5 eliminate
the Knight and then put the Rook on C8
put the queen on B8 and win the game
there's very little black can do about
this if let's say Rook to B7 you will
play Queen to d8 and now okay Bishop to
C6 stops The Rook but now comes Bishop
to C5 now you are ready to to start
capturing here and if Rook to D7
attacking the queen queen will just go
back to B6 again now you're threatening
to capture the Knight and then pick up
the bishop and once the bishop moves now
you've accomplished all you need Queen
to B8 and now there's no stopping Bishop
captures on E7 followed by Rook to see8
and then it's just game over so there is
only one way to do it you can do it many
other ways uh but yeah of course nhel
knows this and he knows that there's no
point in continuing this after Queen to
B6 uh so yeah tough break for Vincent
yesterday losing that game to hard game
to yes Peno but he bounces back now to
this game against Nial serin and like I
said it was a very very close to Nial
actually holding this where it was
whether he mixed up lines because I
really doubt it with um with the Vincent
playing like the the uh 12th most
popular continuation here with Rook D1 I
mean you might have the the top four
maybe even the top six ready from the
top of your head you know know
everything by heart but I I I refuse to
believe that you know the the 12th most
popular continuation you know the the a
couple of top engine lines so yeah very
nicely played by by Vincent he
definitely outplayed him and you know a
nice Victory 30 moves against a strong
player like Niall uh great stuff uh so
yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it I will check at least one
more game from this round as it's also
very important for the final standings
and the final standings will decide the
the two candidates for the FIA
candidates tournament I would like to
thank chess beats League Roma manini
Sams giant ttis far Marvin Sparrow and
Gart hlan for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions but also just uh uh covering
this turn tournament until it finishes
uh so thank you all I will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day
and once again big congratulations to
those of you who found both pause the
video moments but also who solved the
second POS the video moment during the
first POS the video moment see you
soon